If our game players are looking for
a freemium game,
we still want to include them
in our monetization strategy.
How do we do that?
>> To monetize all our players,
we can use ads which make small amounts
of money each time they are displayed.
>> Ads have become more and more common
in game apps in the past few years, and
the revenue they generate
has increased every year.
>> That's great, but
what kind of profit can an individual
developer expect to get from these ads?
>> Well, a typical profit for every
thousand ads shown is about two dollars,
so to really make a profit from ads
you need to display a lot of them.
>> But remember, not by overwhelming
your players with constant ads, but
by showing a few of them to lots and
lots of players.
>> Let's look at the different types
of ads that game developers use.